gráficas 0.6 en la recta numérica
tenemos una recta numérica aquí que va
de 0 a 1 está dividida en 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 partes iguales hay 10 de estos
espacios del 0 al 1 entonces entre cada
uno de estos espacios por ejemplo en
este primer espacio entre estas dos
rayas hay un espacio representado por
una décima es una de las diez partes
iguales una décima de la distancia
nosotros queremos graficar 0.6 este 6
está en el lugar de las décimas entonces
este decimal representa 6 décimas como
fracción es 6 sobre 10
eso es seis décimas entonces si uno de
estos espacios representa una de diez
partes iguales y queremos seis décimas
entonces necesitamos avanzar en la
región numérica seis de esas partes
iguales es decir seis décimas de las
diez décimas totales
iniciando en cero avanzamos 1 2 3 4 5 6
y grafica mos en este punto esto es 0.6
6 décimas